Gary how to keep her productivity so
damn high you know for me there's only
one real answer it's not a very scalable
answer to everybody else the truth is my
productivity is very high because of
gratitude I'm so outrageously grateful
for the fact that I was born in Belarus
which is the last dictatorship in Europe
I was born in the Soviet Union and
communism as a pure 100% capitalist and
was born in a time when the Soviet Union
was struggling and they traded people
leaving the Soviet Union because nobody
could leave the country I was able to
leave the country because Israel and the
United States made a pact to get Jews
out of Russia by trading wheat I was
traded for wheat right so I was born
luckily at a moment we're in a communist
regime where I was able to get out of
there
I was able to come to the greatest
capitalistic country in the world I was
born to two incredibly amazing parents
for different reasons
my mom building my self-esteem to a
point where I think I can do anything
my dad teaching me that which saved my
ass because boy am i [ __ ] or at
heart right and so I you know
unfortunately I lost three of my
grandparents before I was four so I've
basically never known a lot of death in
my family I've been given the one talent
that really I think over indexes for
successful which is salesmanship and
business skills and so my productivity
very honestly is completely predicated
on the gratitude of the things that I've
been gifted and I just can't let all
that good stuff down I I feel like I'm I
can't let it down I mean I was so lucky
it's up to me to to do the right thing
with it and so gratitude is how I the
best answer